hello everyone i'm going to talk about
our favorite on the symmetric sparse
building matrix factorization and
applications it's a joint work with
sanctions from uc berkeley johnson from
adobe research and windjoe talk from
columbia university
here's the outline of my talk first i
will give you some backgrounds on
non-negative matrix factorization
problems and experience and also some
motivations from theoretical computer
science and machine learning then i'll
show you our main results
next i will tell you some techniques of
designing every case algorithm for
sparse non-negative matrix factorization
and also
in analyzing the non-singularity of
sparse boolean matrix
finally i will show you some open
questions
let's get started from the introduction
so what is the amf problem here's the
definition
suppose you are giving
your matrix m
with dimension n by m and also a right
parameter r you need to find two
matrices w1 and w2 with non-negative
increase
such that for n by r matrix w1 and m
biometrics l2 the distance between w1
times w2 transpose and m is minimized
here the distance metric can be l 0 norm
or the ethno
this problem has been studied over
decades and has many applications in
different fields include image
segmentation document classroom
or even music transcription
an nmf has some important variants the
first kind of variance is the symmetric
emf which means the two vectors w1 and
w2 should be equal
this problem relates to the kernel
k-means and also graph classroom the
second kind of variance is a binary
value in mmf
where w1 and w2 should have binary value
increase
for example 0 or 1 or plus minus 1.
which relates to the ldp sequel or graph
partition
the third variance is the sparse mmf
where we restrict w1 and w2 to be used
bars or columns bars
in our paper we focus on the problem
that has all of these three kinds of
variants that is we study the sparse
symmetric boolean matrix factorization
problem
or ss bmf problem
here's the formal definition suppose you
are giving a symmetric matrix m
and
after making n by n and
a velocity primary k and rank parameter
r
you need to find
a
your case sparse matrix w
in m by argument
and also with boolean entries such that
there are zero distance between m and w
transpose is minimized
why should we care about this problem
because it has many important or natural
motivations from theoretical computer
science and machine learning
the first
tcs motivation is a complete
decomposition problem
here we regard the input matrix m as the
adjacency matrix of a graph key
then the factor w just encode
a click cover of g
which partitions the edges of g into
several clicks
note that the js column of w indicates
which vertices belongs to the js click
and the sparsity parameter k
as a consume that each vertex should
belong to exactly k clicks
this is an example of a graph with nine
vertices and we partition it into
six clicks and each vertex belongs to
exactly two clicks
if we solve ssbmf then we will find such
a quick decomposition
giving only the agency matrix of the
graph
and this problem can be used to identify
community structure of a social network
the second motivation in tcs is about
the line graph of hyper graphs here we
regard w as the edge vertex
incidence matrix of a k uniform have a
graph with m hyper edges and r vertices
then the input matrix m
is just the agency matrix of the line
graph of h
where
the line graph base
the graph with vertices corresponds to
the hyper edges of the half graph h
and two edges
under the
two edges are
connected in the line graph if an only
if they
have
some common vertices in the hypograph
in this setting ssbmf asks for
reconstructing the hypograph from its
line graph
notice that this formula is primary
parameterized by an important factor k
when k equals to r the hypergraph
becomes the graph and this problem was
fully characterized by the witness
0
and many efficient or even nearly linear
time algorithm has been proposed to
solve the reconstruction problem
unfortunately when k is greater than 2
no such theorem exists and even
determining whether a given graph is the
line graph of some k uniform hypergraph
is np complete problem
it turns out to be a worst case harness
of ss emf problem so if we assume p
naught is equal to np then we cannot
hook any polynomial time algorithm to
exactly
factorize
giving an arbitrary matrix n with the
condition of ssbmf
we also found some motivations in
machine learning
so if we solve the ssbmf problem then it
will implies some attacks on the inside
scheme which is the scheme for privacy
cleaning your network on images while
have little effects on the cleaning
accuracy
it constructs the synthetic training
data
using
some random k-linear combinations of k
private images
after this scheme was proposed some
attacks on this game were also proposed
and they are
implicitly use the ssbmf problem
roughly speaking they showed how to form
the so-called grand matrix app
whose ij's entry indicates whether the
sense of private images that give rise
to the synthetic image ing overlap
then
the optimal solution w
will tell you which privacy images were
used to generate each synthetic image
and this kind of information is very
helpful to recover the private images
from the synthetic cleaning image
also the attack
algorithm imply the average case
algorithm for ssbmf because each
synthetic image is generated from a
random
linear combination of private images
however these algorithms are either
heuristic
and lack of probable guarantees or only
works for certain parameters
in our paper we focus on
the average case
ssbmf
namely we just assumed that ichigo
of the ground truth matrix w
is an independent uniformly random
k-sparse boolean vector
and we form the input matrix m to be w
times w transpose
here the matrix multiplication is over
boolean semi green
where
the addition operator is the logical r
and
the multiplication operator corresponds
to logical n
we
show that
when the dimension of m is large enough
then there exists an algorithm that
takes at the input m and runs in o of
m to the omega plus one time where omega
is the matrix multiplication exponent
then with high probability over the
randomness of w is we are also the
matrix w hat
such that the columns of w hat equals to
the columns of w up to a permutation
second we also give a worst case
guarantee for the approximate
ssbmf
or even
sparse nmf
so suppose you have a symmetric matrix m
with integer entries
and the right parameter r and some
accuracy parameter epsilon then there is
an algorithm that runs in classic
polynomial time and output and epsilon
approximate matrix example has such that
w hat
is your k sparse
and the distance between
w has w hat transfers and m
is only epsilon times n
worse than the optimal solution
here the matrix multiplication can be
either over integer domain or over the
boolean seminary
and we know that our algorithm is based
on a crisis for normal time
to csp solver proposed by
manu gangsi and most corpus
as a consequence our algorithm also
implies an algorithm for the best k
vector sum problem
here's the definition
suppose there exists
a hidden data set x consisting of
r d the minimum vectors x 1 to x r
however
we are only giving access to
some other n vectors y 1 2 y m
with the promise that each y vector
is generated by first choosing a set s
of size k and sum of all the vectors in
of x in this set
and the goal of the bkb sum problem is
to recover the sets s1 to sn
moreover we assume that we are giving
access to a similarity oracle
where with the input ion gate the oracle
will tell you the size of
the intersection between sets si and sk
also we assume that each set sk is
uniformly random k subset
it's easy to see that this problem is
quite close to the ssbmf problem
and
also
this problem is a mathematical abstract
of the attacks on insert height
find our every case algorithm for ssbmf
we can show that
for a bkva sum instance together with a
similarity oracle there is an m to the
omega plus 1 plus d times r times n time
algorithm that
approximately recovers the magnitude of
the heavy quantities of every vector in
the hidden data set here
we say a coordinate is having a phase
magnitude is omega k times the average
value of any original vector in that
coordinate
so we can not only recover the set s1 to
sm but we can also extract some
information
from the hidden data site
now let's switch here to our average
phase algorithm
in the ssbmf problem we are giving
access to the matrix m
written as w times w transpose
for some w that we want to find
but it can also be written as the sum of
each column of w we say w i
tensor product w i tensor
wi
where the
multiplication and addition operations
is over the boolean semi grain
now suppose we can form a
three-dimensional tensor t
which is w i think the writings at wi
over the integer domain and we further
assume that
each columns of w
is linearly independent over the year
then we can simply draw a standard
tensor decomposition algorithm for
example the young algorithm to recover
everyone to wr up to a permutation
therefore
based on this high level idea we will
have two technical steps the first is to
both trap the tensor t giving only the
matrix n
and second we need to show that
the columns of w are linearly
independent with high probability
let's first look at the first step both
trapping the tensor
normally we need to both grab third
order information w it's written that
apply from the second order information
between m
let's consider the bkb sum set where
each w i indicate
whether
the
vector
j
is in
some hidden set s i for some k subside
sr
then
we can interpret
an
entry of the tensor t
as the size of the intersection
between s a and s b and s c
the simpsons
the
matrix m tells us whether two subsets
intersect
now the question becomes how to estimate
the size of people in the sessions
giving only some
indicators of
inter of the intersection between two
subsets
the first step is to apply some
inclusion exclusion principle to express
the
intersection between three subsets
as some
unions
of three or two subsets
then we give a method that can compute
the size of
any l subsets u for any error
we first look at the probability that
randomly choosing t subset of r does not
intersect any of
the l subsets s1 to say
by simple combinatorics we can show that
this quantity can be computed by
this
formula
which does not depend on what exactly
the subsets s1 to slash but only depends
on the size of the uni of them
so we denoted as mu sub the size of the
unit
then
by an observation we show that
when r is large enough
mu sub t is a monotonically decreasing
sequence and they are also well
separated
which means if we can estimate mu sub s1
to sls unit within some error of order
kor
then the size of the unit can be exactly
decoded from our estimate
so how to estimate this probability
notice that each column of the
information's m gives a sample of a
random k subset v
and v has no intersection with s1 to sl
if the entries in this corresponding use
are all zero simultaneously
therefore
we can just count the fraction of such
columns in m
to estimate mu with high accuracy as
long as
the dimension of m or in other words the
number of samples is large enough
here's the sudoku of our main algorithm
it consists of two parts first we form
the tensor t using the
previous size approach
and then we run the standard yaris
algorithm on the scissor t
what is the run time of our algorithm
for the first part the time consuming
step is to estimate
the probability mu sub a and b and c
now evenly it will take m to the fourth
time
by using
some batch techniques and fast matrix
multiplication it can be improved to o
of m to the omega plus one time
and for the second part it is known that
the young algorithm can be done in ample
omega time therefore our every case of
rhythm takes m to the omega plus one
time
what about the correctness
the correctness of the first part was
already analyzed in previous slides
for the second part in order to
correctly decompose the tensor the young
algorithm
needs the
columns of the ground truth's
matrix w to be linearly independent
how can we show this happens with high
probability
so we need to analyze the
non-singularity of sparse boolean
random matrix
before looking at the sparse case let's
consider
an independent case where the matrix is
generated
with independent plus minus one or zero
one increase
then what is the probability that the
matrix is singular
it's an old
mathematics problem and it was shown to
be later on one in 1967 and then it was
sequentially improved
to one half plus later over 1 to the r
which is believed to be a right alphabet
in our case however the interest of w
are not fully independent but there
exists some dependence within a year
since they require that the yo sum
equals to k
in the dependent setting
there are this sound works that study
the dense case which means the velocity
function k equals to omega of log of r
and for the constant k it was congested
that the agency matrix of
a random k regular graph
is singular with probability later of
one for k at least three and it was
fully resolved in a recent paper
it's still a little different from our
setting since our w corresponds to the
agency matrix of a random bipartite
graph is only left singularity but not
left and right singularity
so here's the definition of our problem
let's w be a matrix whose use are id
random vectors
each falling from the uniform
distribution over 0 1 to r with exact
same payments
then for constant k what is the
singularity probability of w
or equivalently if we want to achieve
the singularity probability to be little
o of 1 how small of m can we choose
we remark size by a simple net argument
when m is at least r square
then the matrix w is not only full rank
but also polynomial condition
however we want to achieve nearly
optimal sample capacity so how can we
improve this naive law about
we first consider the case when k is an
old number
then we
observe that
the
linear independence of the column of w
in
r can be reduced
to the linear independence in f2
therefore we only need to compute the
probability that w is singular in f2
and we show that when m is at least r
over k times log of r then with high
probability w
column will be linearly independent over
f2
and then by the reduction also linearly
independent over r
how can we prove this it's quite
straightforward we just need to bound
the probability that w times u equals to
0 for some u e f 2 to r
and u is not equal to 0 and this
probability can be bounded by
the sum of probability that for some u
with exactly lambda ones the matrix w
times u equal to zero and we denote it
as p of lambda
and this quantity is related to the
binary crosstalk polynomial which has
some known upper bounds for the
magnitude
and then we combine them together
we can guess the
upper bound for the
singularity probability of w over f2
the second case is when k is even
however the previous approach doesn't
work because for all one vector w times
one equals to zero for any w over f two
in our paper we adapt some techniques
in a paper by fibre carbon and solvent
where they study the dense case and we
adapt their techniques to the sparse
setting
suppose we want to compute the
probability that w is column singular
then we consider two cases the first is
w x equal to zero for some x with
support of size less than r
and the second case is w x equals zero
for some x base four support
for the first case since the bad event
is w times one vector equals zero and
since the x does not have full support
then it can
still be reduced to the f2 case
and for the second case when x has full
support
we use the techniques in the sks 20
paper to look at the fiber of the vector
x where the fiber means the set of all
indices whose entries are equal to a
particular value
when x has a large fiber which means
most of the accuracy in x
are the same
then it can be easily upper bounded by
some simple estimates for the second sub
case when x has only small fibers it's a
little tricky we use some tools in group
theoretic
later we offer
inequality to upper bound the
anti-concentration
and also we use a trick in
20 that transforms the distribution of
of a bernoulli random vector to a
distribution of random k sparse vector
pull them together we can show that when
m is at least max of r and rot times log
of r then with high probability the
columns of w are linearly independent
over r for even k
now combining the even and all the cases
together we can show that
for any w with your k squares as long as
m is large enough
the columns of w are linearly
independent or r with high probability
then this theorem implies that the
assumption of young algorithm will hold
for most of the random w
which proves the correctness of our
every case algorithm
finally let me tell you some open
questions in our work so we have an m to
the one over epsilon times k squared
times log of r times algorithm for the
worst case approximated ssbmf and we
also show that
for the exact version this is np-hard
so can we improve a runtime to some
arbitrary function in terms of kr and
epsilon times polynomial e m for the
approximated ssdmf
or can we show that it is impossible by
proving the hardness of approximation
for ssbmf
probably based on some fungus hypotheses
like exponential time hypothesis eth or
gap eth we know that the prayer work by
ayurveda
and moisture has some nmf algorithms and
lower bounds and their techniques might
be helpful to resolve this open question
the second open question is related to
the batch k vector sum problem
our every case algorithm implies an
every case algorithm or basically vector
sum which has some applications in
machine learning security
so can we find more applications of the
best key vector sound problem in quick
photography
and on the other hand the best tribeca
sound problem is closely related to the
k-sun problem where the averages harness
of k-sun was recently proved what about
the average case harness of best cave
accessories
thanks for your time